hello everyone after more than 14
thousand of you have voted we have a
winner for our next series the winner is
2013 candidates tournament it was it was
a tournament played in England in a
building called Savoy place and it was a
double it was an eight-player double
round-robin not like the 1959 candidates
tournament where everyone played four
times against everyone else so everyone
will face each other twice and since
this is the first video we're making
this in this series I think it would be
a nice idea to introduce the players so
let's start first we have Magnus Carlsen
of course everyone knows we is now but
even then before he even entered the
candidates tournament or even before he
became world champion he was the highest
rated player in this tournament I
believe he was 20 872 almost almost 70
points higher rated than second second
highest rated one mere Kramnik and third
highest rated eleven rnm so he was
already already a well-known star in the
uprising so after Carlson we have eleven
Oregon then after our engine we have
Boris Gelfand after Gelfand we have
Krish Alexander Greece shook and it's
interesting in 2013 when the candidates
tournament was played good Easter who
was the only player out of these eight
who who was a smoker so whenever he
wanted to light a cigarette during
during the games he had to completely
leave the building because there was no
place where he could have a smoke so I
don't know if he still smokes but at
that time I'm sure that was very
annoying for him and he said that he
enjoyed he enjoyed London very much the
only thing he didn't enjoy it was the
was the weather which you know could be
can be kind of annoying when you have to
smoke outside so then we have a Vassily
Yvonne he also gave a lot of drama to
this tournament but you'll see that
after we cover some games then we have
Vladimir Kramnik
also a member of
twenty-eight hundred club in those days
and lastly we have a Peter Svidler with
a very nice haircut so those are the
players and this for round one I will
only show one game it's 11 Origen vs.
Magnus Carlsen Magnus Carlsen was the
favorite going into this tournament
arena and Kramnik were second favorites
so it's a very important game cousin has
the black pieces against Aragon so let's
see this game and round one was a
relatively peaceful but already from
round to do it's gonna it's gonna get
very interesting Aragon opens with the
d4 we have a knight to f6 c4 e6 and
Knight to f3 the anti names of Indian
and the crossing goes for Bishop to b4
this comes with check it's the bow go
Indian defense and it's a defense that
has enjoyed the status of being
extremely solid for for a very long time
it was a favorite opening of players
such as Tigran Petrosian and wolf
Anderson who were who were both known
for their for their defensive skills and
even Boris Spassky employed this opening
during the during the eighties later
when he just wanted to finish finishing
games quickly and you know just as a
nice drawing resource Bishop to b2 who
had Bishop captures Queen captures and
now d5 Knight to c3
we have castles III and Queen to e7 here
Arnim goes for rook to c1 R up to d8 and
now Queen to c2 getting the Queen off of
the D file but other than Queen to c2
later Aragon said that probably best was
C captures on d5 and after C capture see
captures here white could what could
maybe go for some advantage but after
rook to d8 he played Queen to c2 and now
we have a 6 8 3 9 B to d7
Bishop to e2 and D captures on c4
releasing the tension in the center
Bishop captures on c4 and you do have to
capture this immediately even though you
just played a bunch of to e2 you have to
lose a tempo here if you if you can or
something then black can indeed play B 5
and the 5
the c4 pawn after a 4 c6 is perfectly
fine and the black will keep his extra
pawn and a better position so after D
captors on c4 you do have to lose a
temple Bishop captures now comes c5 and
Bishop it back to e2 we have B 5 d
captures on c5 Queen captures on c5 and
b4 now cross and brings the Queen back
we need to Queen back to e7 and now
castles by Oregon Bishop to b7 and here
you could you could probably do a lot of
different different ideas you could
maybe maybe try and bring this night
maybe bring the knight over to b3 maybe
find an outpost on c5 but you know that
Carson is going to play rook a to c8 so
you you do have to do something in this
position Aragon decided to go 84 he
immediately decided to exchange
everything on the Queen side and the
cousin goes forth he plays queen capture
some before pawn captures pawn captures
and now Aragon didn't grab the pawn back
immediately
first he played Queen to be one although
you could you can capture the point
immediately after knife capture some b5
but he probably didn't want to calculate
what happens after rook rook 8 the c8 as
now your knight is attacked here you
have to figure out to have to remove the
Queen what if Bishop captures and then
you can't capture with the bishop
because the knight would be hanging on
b5 so maybe you would have to break your
pawn structure here but it's actually
perfectly fine after Queen to d2
now you force the black to capture as
the Queen is under attack so after Queen
captures Knight captures now there's no
longer a problem of your knight being
attacked on b5 and after be after black
play something like Bishop to e6 simply
captures captures and rope to a one
Bishop captures Bishop captures a
perfectly equal position where white
does have a bishop but it's pretty
meaningless as the play is only on one
side of the board so after this a
capture some b5 we have Queen to be one
first offering a trade of Queens across
and accepts this Queen captures rook
captures and now there there's there is
no way of actually defending the b-pawn
as
attacked three times so Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now look to be eight
by Carlson night capture some b5 we had
nine three five attacking the bishop
night to the d4 and Alba shock captures
night captures and rook captures mb1
rook captures some v1 and if you look at
a position it's pretty much identical
but this is only moved 25 and there was
the 30 move rule you were not allowed to
make a draw unless 30 moves were made of
course you could make a draw by
threefold repetition or you know it's a
stalemate but you could not agree to a
draw and less at least 30 moves were
made on the board so here both Carson
and Aaron decided decided be funny you
know and create something funny on the
board that's all we have h 6 h 3 g5 now
G 4 King g7 King G to rock to d7 rook to
be two rook to C seven Knights to d4
Knight to d5 and here are an implied
Luke 2 C 2 and this is mu 31 so in this
position the players agreed to a draw in
a completely symmetrical position as you
can see here very nice and I don't think
there's I I mean it's it's ok you can't
really force someone not to draw the
game our players will always find a way
to draw the game even if you force them
to make at least 30 moves and then
they're gonna do something like this but
you know if a position is drawn a
position is drawn what I mean oh it's
useful because of course when you have
like a team against team and then you
don't want quick draws like 5 moves and
then draw or no chess was ever played
but in in that position of move 25 that
I don't think that rule should apply
there but regardless so this was the
game from round 1 Levin our inner versus
magnus carlsen and all of the games from
round 1 were drawn so this is the only
game i will show from round 1 and as of
as of tomorrow we're gonna have two
rounds two games for each round or or
more if more than two games will be
interesting
but as of round two already there will
be a lot of craziness so we will always
have at least two interesting games to
show per round so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos see her
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon with a game from round two of the
2013 candidates tournament thank you